let's talk about the best protein for recovery
not just from exercise but from stress from
being sick now you have two things you have
protein that is absorbed in the body okay and then
you have protein that's actually used by the body
two different things most the protein is absorbed
but only a small portion is actually utilized and
when i talk about used i'm talking about in the
repair action and also providing the raw material
to build new proteins your body makes about 50,000
proteins a day and what i'm talking about is
proteins are different combinations of amino acids
and you might be thinking protein only as
muscle right but you have hair you have nails
you have tendons ligaments fascia which
is the outer covering or connective tissue
around different things you have cartilage
you have your skin dna rna all the cellular
machines inside the cell are made with proteins
enzymes are made with proteins both digestion
and in chemical pathways hormones are made from
proteins what about lipoproteins like hdl or ldl
that's proteins that carries the cholesterol
through the blood blood is protein and your
immune system is protein so a lot of your body is
protein and so when you consume dietary protein
only a portion of that protein is utilized by
the body for this and this the rest is either
wasted through the kidney or used as fuel
because it converts to glucose the way they
measure how much protein is being wasted or used
for fuel versus use is by the nitrogen in the
urine and that way you can tell the utilization
percentage at the top of the list we have breast
milk of course this is not available to most
people unless you are an infant but that's 49.6%
so we're going to go with the egg okay egg is
number two but out of most proteins this is pretty
high you get a 49% utilization so eggs are a really
good protein to use in recovery but check this out
let's say you're into bodybuilding and
you're taking all this whey protein
for recovery or you want to grow your muscles look
at this it's only 17% compared to eggs which is 49%
that means that you're only using 17% the rest is
waste or fuel look at this soy protein 16% it's in
a lot of protein bars it's in a lot of diet shakes
it's going to end up with a lot of glucose right
here and then look at this branch chain amino
acids one percent utilization the rest is either
waste or fuel you might be thinking oh i have
to take some branched chain amino acids because
i need to repair my muscles well it might be only
benefiting you from the fuel standpoint because
branched chain amino acids is not complete
and any time you are trying to repair or
build muscle you need a complete protein now
there is one blend of essential amino acids
that can give you a 99% utilization
rate and only a one percent waste
or a fuel it's called keto aminos i put a
link down below if you want more data on that
but that's not actually a dietary protein
it would be more of a supplement to assist
in the recovery process hey before you go real
quick i have a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i want
you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is
focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today